the town of chacas qu is located 80
kilometers northwest of Istanbul this
may look like just another quiet summer
day but many of the local residents are
concerned about the recent protests in
Turkey's largest city many people here
work for German companies for example
there's a huge bush siemens factory here
that makes household appliances other
German firms supply component parts the
PAS company makes cable assemblies for
washing machines many of the workers
have been following the demonstrations
on TV but none of them are willing to
speak to us on camera Fatih Kerman is
the company's managing director you grew
up in a Turkish family in Germany and
moved to Turkey seven years ago Hermann
believes the police crackdown on
demonstrators in Istanbul went too far
of course you get upset when you see
these pictures particularly the response
of the police it wasn't necessary on the
other hand I think this is a part of the
process of democratization in Turkey
German companies invested more than 600
million euros in Turkey last year until
recently Turkey was considered
politically stable and a good place for
foreign companies to invest now the mood
has grown tense German is very careful
as he expresses his thoughts about the
current political situation in his
country I believe the government
understands that its fate depends on the
country's economic success because of
the recent events the government should
engage in some self-criticism and then
try to correct the things that happened
that were wrong and then it needs to try
to increase its support in society as a
whole
this is the plum company another German
firm that makes parts for various
industries the company's head office is
in often Sudan nor John has been the
company's managing director for ten
years he too spent a lot of time living
in Germany with his wife and daughter
nor John visited Ghazi Park in Istanbul
before it was cleared by police the
employees here are divided over the
recent demonstrations some of them
support Prime Minister erawan others
backed the protesters go there myself
we talked about the demonstrations at
home but I'd rather not comment
I don't want to see anything bad happens
things should be done in the interests
of the people there have been protests
demonstrations and meetings and they've
caused problems for some people I'm glad
that people are expressing their
dissatisfaction they reacted and I think
that's a good thing
Quran or John would like to see his
country join the European Union and he
hopes that recent events have not
damaged Turkey's reputation for the
international community it's going to
take some time the negotiations on
Turkey joining the EU will resume I
think that both sides will end up
sitting at the table and talking to each
other once again but for the time being
it looks as though Turkey is moving
farther away from the European Union